when people find out I write about time
management they assume two things one is
that I'm always on time
and I'm not I have four small children
and I would like to blame them for my
occasional tardiness but sometimes it's
just not their fault
I was once late to my own speech on time
management
we all had to just take a moment
together and savor that irony the second
thing they assume is that I have lots of
tips and tricks for saving bits of time
here and there sometimes I'll hear from
magazines that are doing a story along
these lines generally on how to help
their readers find an extra hour in the
day and the idea is that we will shave
bits of time off every day activities
add it up and we'll have time for the
good stuff and I question the entire
premise of this piece but I'm always
interested in hearing what they've come
up with before they call me so some of
my favorites doing errands in a way
where you only have to make right-hand
turns being extremely judicious in
microwave usage so it says three to
three and a half minutes on the package
we are totally getting in on the bottom
side of that and my personal favorite
which makes sense on some level is to
DVR your favorite shows so you can
fast-forward through the commercials and
that way you save about eight minutes
every half-hour
so in the course of two hours of
watching TV you find 32 minutes to
exercise which is true you know another
way to find 32 minutes to exercise don't
watch two hours of TV a day right
anyway the ideas will save bits of time
here and there are added up we will
finally get to everything we want to do
but after studying how successful people
spend their time and looking at their
schedules hour by hour I think this idea
has it completely backward we don't
build the lives we want by saving time
we build the lives we want and then time
saves itself here's what I mean I
recently did a time diary project
looking at a thousand and one days in
the lives of extremely busy
women they had demanding jobs sometimes
their own businesses kids to care for
maybe parents to care for community
commitments busy busy people I had to
keep track of their time for a week so I
could add up how much they worked and
slept and I interviewed them about their
strategies for my book one of the women
whose time logs I studied she goes out
for a Wednesday night for something she
comes home to find that her water heater
has broken and there is now water all
over her basement if you've ever had
anything like this happened to you you
know it is a hugely damaging frightening
sopping mess so she's dealing with the
immediate aftermath at night next day
she's got plumbers coming in day after
that professional cleaning crew dealing
with the ruined carpet all this is being
recorded on her time log winds up taking
seven hours of her week seven hours
that's like finding an extra hour in the
day but I'm sure if you had asked her at
the start of the week could you find
seven hours to train for a triathlon
could you find seven hours to mentor
seven worthy people I'm sure she would
have said what most of us would have
said which is no can't you see how busy
I am yet when she had to find seven
hours because there is water all over
her basement
she found seven hours and what this
shows us is that time is highly elastic
we cannot make more time but time will
stretch to accommodate what we choose to
put into it and so the key to time
management is treating our priorities as
the equivalent of that broken water
heater and to get at this I like to use
some language from one of the busiest
people I ever interviewed by busy I mean
she was running a small business of 12
people on the payroll she had six
children in her spare time I was getting
in touch with her to set up an interview
on how she had it all that phrase I
remember it was a Thursday morning and
she was not available to speak with me
of course right but the reason she was
unavailable to speak with me is that she
was out for a hike because it was a
beautiful spring morning and she wanted
to go for a hike so of course this makes
me even more intrigued and when I
finally do catch up with her she
explains it like this she says listen
Laura
everything I do every minute I spend is
my choice and rather than say I don't
have time to do X Y or Z should say I
don't do X Y or Z because it's not a
priority I don't have time often means
it's not a priority if you think about
it that's really more accurate language
I mean I could tell you I don't have
time to dust my blinds but that's not
true if you offered to pay me a hundred
thousand dollars to go dust my blinds I
would get to it pretty quickly since
that is not going to happen I can
acknowledge this is not a matter of
lacking time is that I don't want to do
it using this language reminds us that
time is a choice and granted there may
be horrible consequences for making
different choices I will give you that
but we are smart people and certainly
over the long run we have the power to
fill our lives with the things that
deserve to be there so how do we do that
how do we treat our priorities as the
equivalent of that broken water heater
well first we need to figure out what
they are I want to give you two
strategies for thinking about this the
first on the professional side I'm sure
many people coming up to the end of the
year or giving or getting annual
performance reviews you look back over
your successes over the year your
opportunities for growth and this serves
its purpose but I find it's more
effective to do this looking forward so
once you pretend is the end of next year
you're giving yourself a performance
review and it has been an absolutely
amazing year for you professionally what
three to five things did you do that
made it so amazing so you can write next
year's performance review now and you
can do this for your personal life too
I'm sure many of you like me come
December get cards that contain these
folded up sheets of colored paper on
which is written what is known as the
family holiday letter bit of a wretched
genre of literature really going on
about how amazing everyone in the
household is or even more scintillating
how busy everyone in the household is
but these letters sir
purpose which is that they tell your
friends and family what you did and your
personal life that matter to you over
the course of the year so this year's
kind of done but I want you to pretend
it's the end of next year and it has
been an absolutely amazing year for you
and the people you care about what 3 to
5 things did you do that made it so
amazing so you can write next year's
family holiday letter now don't send it
please don't send it but you can write
it and now between the performance
review and the family holiday letter we
have a list of six to ten goals we can
work on in the next year and now we need
to break these down into doable steps so
maybe you want to write a family history
well first you can read some other
family histories get a sense for the
style then maybe think about the
questions you want to ask your relatives
set up appointments to interview them or
maybe you want to run a 5k so you need
to find a race and sign up and figure
out a training plan and dig those shoes
out of the back of the closet and then
this is key we treat our priorities as
the equivalent of that broken water
heater by putting them into our
schedules first and we do this by
thinking through our weeks before we are
in them I find a really good time to do
this is Friday afternoons Friday
afternoon is what an economist might
call a low opportunity cost time most of
us are not sitting there on Friday
afternoons saying I am excited to make
progress toward my personal and
professional priorities right now but we
are willing to think about what those
should be so take a little bit of time
Friday afternoon make yourself a three
category priority list career
relationships self making a three
category list reminds us that there
should be something in all three
categories career we think about
relationships self not so much but
anyway just a short list two to three
items in each then look out over the
whole of the next week and see where you
can plan them in where you plan them in
is up to you and I know this is going to
be more complicated for some people than
others I mean
some people's lives are just harder than
others it is not going to be easy to
find time to take that poetry class if
you are caring for multiple children on
your own I get that and I don't want to
minimize anyone's struggle but I do
think that the numbers I am about to
tell you are empowering there are 168
hours in a week 24 times seven is a
hundred sixty eight hours that is a lot
of time if you are working a full-time
job so 40 hours a week sleeping eight
hours a night so 56 hours a week
that leaves 72 hours for other things
that is a lot of time you say you're
working 50 hours a week maybe a main job
in a side hustle well that leaves 62
hours for other things you say you're
working 60 hours well that leaves 52
hours for other things you say you're
working more than 60 hours well are you
sure
there was once a study comparing
people's estimated work weeks with time
diaries found that people claiming 75
plus hour work weeks were off by about
25 hours you can guess in which
direction right anyway in 168 hours a
week I think we can find time for what
matters to you if you want to spend more
time with your kids you want to study
more for a test you're taking you want
to exercise for three hours and
volunteer for two you can and that's
even if you're working way more than
full time hours so we have plenty of
time which is great because guess what
we don't even need that much time to do
amazing things but when most of us have
bits of time what do we do pull out the
phone right start deleting emails or
otherwise we're puttering around the
house or watching TV but small moments
can have great power you can use your
bits of time for bits of joy maybe it's
choosing to read something wonderful on
the bus on the way to work I know when I
had a job that required two bus rides in
a subway ride every morning I used to go
to the library on weekends to get stuff
to read made the whole experience all
just almost enjoyable breaks at work can
be used for meditating or praying if
family dinner is out because of your
crazy work schedule maybe family
breakfast could be a good substitute
it's about looking at the whole of one's
time and seeing where the good stuff can
go I truly believe this there is time
even if we are busy we have time for
what matters and when we focus on what
matters we can build the lives we want
in the time we've got thank you
[Applause]